شيئا فشيئا تتحول اسرائيل الى عبء على
داعميها وهي التي امنت في ظل حمايتهم
العقوبه عقودا طواله كانت تحتل اراضي
الفلسطينيين وتتوسع فيها فان قاوموه
قتلتهم بتهمه الارهاب وصرخت في وجه العالم
لا سيما الغربي هل تسمحون بهول كوست اخر
لنا الم تقولوا ان ذلك لن يحدث مره اخرى
تمسك اسرائيل بخناق العالم وتردد وهي التي
لم تجف يدها يوما من الدم الفلسطيني انها
ضحيه الارهاب المهدد وجودها يوم الجمعه
الس 26 عشر من شهر يناير تسقط محكمه العدل
الدوليه قناع
الضحيه تقرر المحكمه ان على اسرائيل
الامتناع عن ارتكاب اي افعال ذات طبيعه
عباديه ضد الفلسطين في غزه وانه يجب عليها
اتخاذ خطوات فوريه تمكن من توفير
المساعدات الانسانيه التي يحتاج اليها
الفلسطينيون بشكل عاجل وهو ما يعني عمليا
رفع الحصار المطبق الذي تفرضه على
القطاع انتصرت جنوب افريقيا لنفسها
وفلسطينيين ولكل احرار العالم الذين تاذت
سيتهم برؤيه استسهال سفك الدم في غزه على
يد الجيش
الاسرائيلي حملت جنوب افريقيا قضيه الشعب
الفلسطيني الى محكمه العدل الدوليه متهمه
اسرائيل بانتهاك اتفاقيه الامم المتحده
لمنع جريمه الاباده الجماعيه وجاءت جنوب
افريقيا الى المحكمه بحساسيه عاليه تجاه
الظلم والعدل كليهما ف ذك هو ميراثها
الاخلاقي من نضال شعبها الافريقي ضد الفصل
العنصري على يد استعماري بيض عتاه غلاظ هم
بقيه من هجمه استعماريه ما سلمت منها
القاره الافريقيه ما ثنى جنوب افريقيا ولا
اخافها من تغضب
بمقاضاته الحكم كانت اسرائيل اول المنكرين
الشاجبة
يصادف اليوم العالميه لتذكر الهولوكوست
تلك مفارقه لكنها تواتي نتنياهو لتكريس
صوره
الضحيه ان اتهام اسرائيل بارتكاب الاباده
الجماعيه ليس اتهاما كاذبا فحسب بل هو
مشين كذلك وعلى الناس الفضلاء في كل انحاء
العالم رفضه وفي اليوم العالمي لتذكر
الهولوكوست اتعهد بصفه رئيس لوزراء
اسرائيل بعدم السماح بحصول هولوكوست ثان
ان هم الفضلاء الذين عناهم نتنياهو انها
الاداره الامريكيه التي اكد متحدث فيها من
الخارجيه ومن مجلس الامن القومي ان اتهام
اسرائيل بارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه لا اساس
له من الصحه في بريطانيا سيعبر متحدث باسم
الخارجيه البريطانيه عن قلق بلاده من قرار
المحكمه لانه لا يساعد في ارساء وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار ويزيد المتحدث
بوصف قرار جنوب افريقيا تقديم القضيه الى
المحكمه بالخاطئ
والاستفزاز اما في الاتحاد الاوروبي فلا
تجد اسرائيل ما يكفي من الناس الفضلاء فقد
ابلغت المفوضيه الاوروبيه اسرائيل بان
عليها الالتزام بقرار محكمه العدل الدوليه
الذي حذرها من انها تخاطر بارتكاب اباده
جماعيه في قطاع غزه ما لم يتم الاخذ بما
قررته المحكمه من اج
لا تملك محكمه العدل الدوليه سلطه انفاذ
قراراتها لكن السلطه القانونيه والاخلاقيه
لقراراتها يمكن تحويلها الى راس مال سياسي
ذلك ما تسعى اليه الجزائر بطلبها عقد جلسه
لمجلس الامن يوم الاربعاء المقبل لبحث
كيفيه تنفيذ قرارات المحكمه في الامم
المتحده يظل الامين العام انطونيو جوتيريش
متمسكا بمقاربات التي ترى ان اصل العنف في
المنطقه هو استمرار
الاحتلال الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يجب ان
ينتهي انه لامر غير مقبول ما تضمنه الرفض
الواضح والمكرر الاسبوع الماضي من اعلى
سلطه في اسرائيل برفض حل
الدولتين يوم الاربعاء ستواجه القوى
العظمى حال انعقاد المجلس السؤال السياسيه
والاخلاقيه ما هي فاعله بقرارات محكمه
العدل الدوليه لكم سيكون الامر صعبا ان
تكون فاضلا من وجهه النظر الاسرائيليه انه
امر قد لا يكلف سقوط الاقنعه عن الفضلاء
فحسب بل سقوط مزاعم ريادته الاخلاقيه
والحضاريه يقول احرار العالم